hello
my name is barbara vanderpall and i'm
speaking to you today from my office at
the university of alabama at birmingham
school of medicine
i've been involved in std laboratory
diagnostics for more than 30 years and
so it's my very real pleasure to talk to
you today about the 2014 cdc guidelines
for laboratory diagnostics of chlamydia
and gonorrhea that came out in march of
this year
of course i'll start with disclosures
and this is a list of sponsors from whom
i've received research or consulting
support over the last two years
i've organized the topics that i want to
go over with you today to talk about why
we're screening because i feel like
sometimes we forget that chlamydia and
gonorrhea are still very relevant
infections and i want to provide you
with some up-to-date data to remind you
that they're actually quite important i
do then want to talk to you about how
the guidelines were developed
what the recommendations actually are
and then how these might impact both
practice both clinical practice and
laboratory practice
so i'm going to start by telling you
things that you surely already know or
you wouldn't be tuning into this webinar
so chlamydia and gonorrhea are still the
number one and number two most commonly
reported notifiable diseases in the u.s
i've shown here the numbers that cdc
estimates in terms of the numbers of
cases that were reported in 2012
and what you see is that salmonella is
actually the third most common
notifiable disease and it occurs about
30 times less often than chlamydia and
gonorrhea so
actually
quite quite important i'm sorry that was
300 times less often so we're talking
orders of magnitude of difference so
these are very very prevalent infections
but of course i think we all know that
prevalence really isn't sufficient to
warrant a control program we don't have
control programs for the common cold and
similarly even though they have
consequences of infection we don't have
control programs for herpes simplex
virus nor do we have a control program
for papilloma virus part of the reason
for that is because we don't have
effective strategies for preventing
transmission of those unlike chlamydia
and gonorrhea where we have very
effective treatment and cure strategies
so this is actually some information
that was taken from an article by hudson
colleagues about whether or not
trichomonas vaginalis should be a
notifiable disease but i think that the
points that they raise in this
particular article about the seven
things that you have to be able to
answer yes to
in order to have a notifiable disease
also apply to whether or not we should
have a control program and by having a
control program a piece of that is that
we should actually have
a screening program and that means
detecting asymptomatic infections
so i'm going to talk to you briefly
about the three items that have
underlined here frequency prevalence
health disparities and the costs of
negative outcomes to remind you why
chlamydia control is particularly
important so the first topic there was
frequency and prevalence and i think
many of you again may have seen this and
this is just suggesting that the
chlamydia rates continue to increase in
the us these are data from 1992 to 2012
so we have more than 30 years worth of
data here and we see steady increases in
the rates of total criminal infections
we also see specific rates um increases
in rates among women
so it's very common that people say well
these rates go up because we have
improved assays and that's very very
true we're much better off than when we
only had culture and non-culture but
non-amplified diagnostics we catch many
more infections with these tests
however
those tests were mostly introduced in
the mid to late 1990s which you can
actually see
here the mid to late 90s we still see
increases after that time point
another thing that people say well these
rates are increasing because in fact
we're increasing our testing overall
that is one of the problems with these
data are they don't have good
denominators so we don't actually know
the number of patients that are screened
in order to get these rates that we see
here so while that's a reasonable
argument i think the gc data actually
are fairly convincing to demonstrate
that the chlamydia rates are going up if
it was just a result of improved
diagnostics and improved screening
coverage the gc rates should be going up
at the same time the chlamydia rates go
up and we've not seen that as all at all
you can see that gc has essentially
plateaued at about
100 cases per hundred thousand people
per year
and these are actually data from british
columbia where they have national health
service and so they can look at all the
data from british columbia and bob
brennam's group did this analysis back
in the mid 2000s and so he took data
from 91 to 2003
and he showed steadily declining rates
of chlamydia infection after the onset
of a control program but what you see is
after about 1996 the rates go
dramatically up and they actually in
fact get almost back to where they were
before the control program started
similarly in other countries
and this is a multinational data set
analysis that was done by nicola and
colleagues you can see steadily
increasing rates of chlamydia throughout
the world and these are countries from
western europe australia and new zealand
and it's so this is a very very
consistent pattern that the rates of
chlamydia plain and simply are going up
so the next point on that bullet list
was are there health disparities and
again i think that's pretty obvious and
most of us are familiar with that
information we know that black people in
the us suffer disproportionately from
sexually transmitted infections but
these are data from the national health
and nutrition education survey that is a
nationally representative population
based survey which estimates the overall
prevalence of disease in the population
and this actually shows a decline in
chlamydia rates among blacks until about
the mid-2000s but in fact those rates
are going up and you can see that not
only are the rates going up but the
disparity is actually increasing as well
so that gap is widening rather than
becoming reduced which suggests that we
need to have improved diagnostic options
to reach more people and particularly
people of color
so the two charts that are on the left
here show you the rates in blacks for
both chlamydia and gonorrhea and of
course they're substantially higher you
see at least a two-fold increase for
blacks compared to any other racial
group for chlamydia and you see about a
four to five full increase for gonorrhea
but not only are blacks at higher risk
for these sexually transmitted
infections but people in the deep south
which is where i'm currently working
also have higher risk of infection which
we can see with the red arrow in the
chart on the right
so we have high prevalence we have
health disparities do we have negative
health outcomes from chlamydial
infections and of course the answer is
yes we've known for many many years that
untreated infections can lead to pelvic
inflammatory disease ectopic pregnancy
and tuber tubal factory infertility
this is a really nice set of data from
price and colleagues that was a
meta-analysis of all the very carefully
controlled randomized controlled trials
that actually looked at pid as an
outcome and chlamydia as a risk factor
and from this meta-analysis you can see
here from the different studies you can
see the different amounts of
pid that resulted following chromium
infections and taking that into a
meta-analysis the authors estimated that
a woman has about a 16 chance of
developing pelvic inflammatory disease
following a chlamydial infection now
these were chlamydial infections that
were identified and treated so these are
not long-term multi-year untreated
infections that led to adverse outcomes
but rather infections that were actually
identified and treated so this is pretty
substantial
and in fact their mathematical modeling
estimated that annual screening for
chlamydia could actually reduce the rate
of pelvic inflammatory disease by 61
which would be a substantial health
savings
similar data come from england here is
the
rate of definite and probable pid
diagnosis in england from 2000 to 2008
and 2000 was when they started their
national chlamydia control program in
the uk and what you can see are
declining rates of pid and even more
importantly what you can see is that the
rates are declining the fastest in those
age populations where screening is
recommended for routine screening not
based on any risks or signs and symptoms
again from that multinational data set
that nicolo's group had analyzed here
you see somewhat of a different
pattern where you see decreases in the
rates in some countries including the
western european countries however you
see flat lines in some countries like
the netherlands shown in red in sweden
shown in yellow of course in both of
those countries both the chlamydia rates
and the pid rates are quite low and so
perhaps that's why there's less of an
impact on with chlamydia control
programs
interestingly what's shown here in green
is the data from new zealand new zealand
has the most recently implemented
chlamydia control program of all of
these countries and so potentially
hasn't had time yet to have a noticeable
effect on pid rates so that certainly
bears watching in the future
similarly they have data for ectopic
pregnancy rates but what's interesting
here is we don't see the same clear-cut
pattern in some countries the ectopic
pregnancy rates are going down over the
time period that chlamydia control has
been available and in some rates they're
flatlined or even possibly going up as
we see in the netherlands
but going back to the data from british
columbia and bob brennaman's group they
did an analysis with
the actual pid rates a couple of years
after they had done their initial
finding showing that the rates of
chlamydial infection were going up so
here in blue
you see the increasing rates of
chlamydial infection but in red you see
the decreasing rates of pelvic
inflammatory disease so even though
we're not being effective in actually
stopping chlamydial infections we may be
affected in capturing them earlier and
thereby avoiding some of the downstream
consequences of those infections the
data are somewhat less clear with
ectopic pregnancy which seems to go down
slightly and then rebound again slightly
but the numbers are quite low and it's
unclear how much noise is in this
particular analysis
so when we put all this together i think
that what we say is that case rates are
rising it's factual it's not artifactual
in both women and men
this is not explained solely by improved
testing technologies and we still have
substantial health disparities that we
really need to focus on improved methods
for identifying those cases and treating
those cases more rapidly
however the good news is that pid rates
are decreasing ectopic pregnancy is
somewhat more complicated but it looks
like
at least in terms of the pid rates which
is the most substantial cost burden
health economically speaking we are
having an impact and therefore control
programs are likely warranted for
chlamydia
so
that means that we need treatment
guidelines or we need screening
guidelines and in the us the screening
guidelines are actually described in the
treatment guidelines which makes it a
bit of a misnomer but what you actually
have recommendations for on the right
i've put a chart that shows you the age
probability of ever having a chlamydia
infection you can see that for women
there's actually
a reduction in
benefit for screening in older women
because the highest probability is being
infected is actually when you're below
20 and that probability declines sharply
by the time you're 25. for men there's
no easy clear-cut solution to say
there's an age group so in fact we have
screening recommendations for urogenital
testing for all women who are 25 and
under some of the guidelines not cdc
guidance but other groups recommend less
than 25 so that number is a little bit
variable but in that age range
there's also recommendations in the cdc
guidelines that all women and men who
report risky behavior
be screened at least annually or when
they attend clinic now that risky
behavior may be a new partner partner
change
a high number of partners
intravenous drug use other high-risk
behaviors that have been
typically associated with std risk
the guidelines also recommend that men
have sex with men be tested at least
annually
using genital testing so this is usually
a urinary urethral swab
the newest iteration of the treatment
guidelines which came out in 2010
recommend that extra genital be
screening be performed annually for all
men who have sex with men so this covers
anal rectal screening as well as oral
fear and geotesting
so
part of again going back to the data
from british columbia because they have
national health care data it's very
broadly applicable because it covers the
entire population of british columbia so
here they were able to look at the
prevalence rate in british columbia
which you can see is less than one per
or
less than um 12 1.2 percent pardon me
and the rates in the us are estimated to
be about 3.4 so their rates to begin
with in the general population are much
lower than those in the us
and you can see that a vaccination with
80 percent coverage might eliminate
chlamydial infections within 20 or
within five years after instituting that
program but what you also see is when we
look in green mathematical modeling
suggests that you'll have a sharp
reduction in the number of cases after a
screening program is implemented but
over time the number of cases will rise
and this is the data that i've just
shown you it matches this chart fairly
well
but what's worth noting is that in this
mathematical modeling was predicated on
the assumption that we're covering 80
percent of the people that we've
determined are appropriate for screening
and control efforts so in the us
we've had these screening
recommendations since about 2000 so how
are we doing in terms of coverage
well this is the 2012 data from the
hedis review of medical practice plans
in the u.s and unfortunately what we see
here is that in commercial hmos shown on
the left
we see that the coverage doesn't even
reach 50 percent in commercial ppos it
doesn't reach 50 percent the only groups
that reach 50 percent are those that are
federally assisted and covered by
medicaid
unfortunately you will also notice that
the blue bars are always less than the
orange bars and the blue bars are the
younger population so these are the 16
to 20 year old women
now these data are actually showing you
the proportion of women who actually
made a visit and were eligible for
screening but weren't weren't provided
with the service whether they declined
it or it wasn't offered isn't known
but one of the things that this may
reflect is actual discomfort on the part
of the provider discussing sexual health
with their patient and discomfort on the
part of the patient in asking for sexual
health screening so both of those things
may actually have an impact on
explaining why we're not actually able
to meet the coverage that we need to
meet so that leads me into the
laboratory diagnostic guidelines because
i think that with the new guidelines we
can see that there are actually ways
that we can start to increase our
screening coverage and hopefully provide
excellent quality data for practitioners
to make clinical decisions based on
so i do want to start for a minute by
talking about how the guidelines were
developed because i think it's actually
important to understand what went into
this process
so the 2014 guidelines are the first
update since 2002 for the laboratory
diagnostic guidelines
obviously technology has changed
immensely since 2002 we have so many
more opportunities and options
so that's part of what i want to talk to
you about in terms of how this impacts
what you do in your clinical practice
and in your laboratory
this entire process started in 2008 with
an intensive literature review
we partnered with librarians at the
national institutes of health who
actually helped us do our data review
and pull literature not only from
published articles but also from
peer-reviewed abstracts at meetings
because we really wanted to get
cutting-edge data that might not have
made it into the literature quite yet
we put these articles and these
abstracts into categories and some of
the categories included comparisons of
assays so head-to-head comparisons of
any different assays that we could find
old assays new assays upcoming assays
we looked for articles and abstracts
that talked about evaluations of extra
genital specimens because we knew that
was one of the screening guidelines we
felt we had to provide some data and
some recommendations to help
laboratories support those screening
guidelines and finally we looked for
evaluations of self-obtained specimens
and i'll talk a little bit more about
self-obtained specimens in a few minutes
so in january of 2009 we met as a group
and we did we finalized our
recommendations for the guidelines so
obviously from january 2009 to march of
2014 it was a rocky rocky road to
publication it took us quite a bit of
effort and i want to share with you
one of the reasons why we had trouble
and i'll get there in just a minute
so the first of the recommendations for
the laboratories are what are the class
of tests that's recommended
well this is a really easy answer it's
nats mats gnats so nucleic acid
amplification tests are the way that
everybody should be testing for
chlamydia gonorrhea in any type of
practice or setting really that's the
end of that whole conversation but i'm
gonna keep saying it because it's really
quite important
for the first time we actually have
language in the recommendations that
specifically says the following tests
are not recommended for routine use and
that includes dna probes
eliza's most of the rapid tests that are
currently available on the market so
non-amplification tests are specifically
discouraged it's not just that they're
not the optimal type they really
shouldn't be used because they don't
provide high quality results
another important factor is that
in the guidelines we specifically
mentioned that there's no distinction
for screening versus diagnostic testing
now you'll remember that chlamydia and
gonorrhea infections especially in women
may be asymptomatic the vast majority of
the time 60 to 70 percent of infections
are likely asymptomatic in women
gonorrheal infections in men
are rarely asymptomatic but in women
they may be and chlamydial infections in
both men and women are usually
asymptomatic therefore we really need
screening practices that are not waiting
on people to come into the clinic
because we're talking about people who
don't have signs or symptoms that cue
them to access health care
now of course when you have any
individual coming in to a patient care
setting their symptoms may require some
sort of different workup than the
generic requirements that we put out in
the recommendations so just recognize
that there may be other options there
may be times when culture is required
particularly for gc and i'll talk about
that as i go through but as a general
overarching statement nucleic acid
amplification tests are the way to go
it doesn't matter if patients have
symptoms or don't have symptoms these
tests work perfectly well in either case
okay so now i told you i would talk to
you about why we had problems getting
these recommendations published and in
fact the problems were it's quite
difficult to understand exactly what the
sensitivity and specificity estimates
are for any of the tests for chlamydia
in particular
so chlamydia culture is notoriously
insensitive i've shown here a couple of
graphs that show you what the estimates
might be
for a test when it's compared against
culture and so what you see
here is when we look at a new test and
estimate it against culture and you'll
see that i've mentioned
gp here just as a name of a test
that is actually no longer available but
just for comparison's sake this test was
estimated to have a sensitivity of
approximately
78 percent when it was compared to
culture but when it was compared to
other tests that were nucleic acid-based
tests then its sensitivity dropped to
closer to 70 percent
so the reality is that if we're
comparing something to culture which
sensitivity may be as low as 60 percent
if that new test
it says oh well it has a sensitivity of
80 compared to culture well that may
mean that it's missing the same 40 that
culture missed and it may be as low as
48 sensitivity so for that reason
non-amplified tests are planned simply
no longer recommended for use despite
the sensitivity estimates that might
appear in package inserts
so in 2002
we were still using what we call now the
tarnished gold standard where we were
using culture and perhaps one other
non-amplified test to try and determine
what the true infection status of an
individual was
so the 2002 guidelines were based on
these early evaluations but now in 2009
we recognize that those package insert
data are largely meaningless because
they were compared against a poor
standard
so when we use a poor standard we can
grossly overestimate the sensitivity as
i just mentioned
we can also grossly underestimate the
specificity so for example if we're
comparing to culture and culture only
identifies 60 percent of infections if
we used a nap test that identified 100
of infections we might think that extra
40 percent were false positives so
therefore there was a lot of concern in
the early days of amplified testing that
specificity was poor
in fact we have so much more data now
than we did in 2002 that we actually
know that this is not the case so in
2002 the guidelines recommended
confirmatory testing of positives if the
positive predicted value was below 90
percent and the positive predicted value
in any population is almost always below
90 because that's just the reality of
the populations that we test for
something that has a three percent
population prevalence
now we have next generation tests for
almost every assay that's on the market
now and those tests have improved both
sensitivity and specificity and based on
all the data that were available that we
looked at in our evidence-based review
no confirmatory testing is recommended
now for any of the gnats so if you have
a positive result actions should be
taken on that positive result and no
confirmatory testing should be or should
be ordered
i just want to show you a little bit of
an example of some of the next
generation assays and all i'm trying to
show you in these figures is that
there's actually quite a bit of waffle
room when you look at
the confidence intervals for any of
these tests you'll see they're quite
large so sometimes you'll see that the
actual
point estimates vary widely but the
confidence intervals are almost always
overlapping so it's quite difficult to
say that there's a real difference in
sensitivity between any of these assays
this is um for female specimens in in a
test in a study that we did
in 2000 with one particular vendor
here's the same data for gonorrhea from
female assays or female specimens and
again you see that there are very large
confidence intervals and the point
estimates very somewhat but the reality
is that the sensitivity is always in the
high 80s or high 90s
another way to look at it that i like to
just put together so that i can see all
the data and make my own decisions is we
can look at a venn diagram where in the
middle you see the positives that were
identified by all
of the assays and in the boxes that are
a little bit
darker you'll see
results that were positive by two of the
three assays used in a clinical trial
and then out there
by themselves you'll see those positives
that were positive by only one assay now
this type of diagram doesn't help you
determine if these are true positives or
false positives it's just showing you
that when you really look at it the vast
majority of positives are detected by
two or three of all the assays and so we
actually have very very high confidence
that these assays are performing quite
well
so then if we look at the
recommendations specifically in women
again i'm going to say it over and over
nats are the class of tests that should
be used we did make a recommendation
about the sample type and for women self
or clinician collected vaginal swabs are
the recommended sample type
and the cervical swabs are acceptable
when a pelvic exam is indicated although
i would throw out to you the fact that
vaginal swabs can be collected before a
patient ever actually interacts with a
clinician thus saving the clinician's
time if a provider needs to do a pelvic
exam and needs to actually make some
observations there's no reason they
shouldn't do that but that vaginal swab
can already be sitting and waiting to go
away to the lab and it doesn't take any
of the clinician's time away from doing
patient management to collect that
specimen
first catch urine is acceptable but may
miss up to 10 of infections now this is
language that's taken directly from the
recommendations based on those charts
that i just showed you you could see
that there were really wide confidence
intervals so we don't see statistical
differences
but urine tends to be low in general in
general terms in terms of sensitivity
please note the last line here that and
the cervical swabs for gc culture are
clearly warranted if one suspects that a
patient is a gc treatment failure so you
should collect that sample so that
susceptibilities can be run
now here's some of the data that were
used
are similar to those data that were used
when we determined which sample type to
recommend this is from a particular
study that was done in 2012 and
published last year where you see that
the sensitivity of the vaginal swab was
highest followed by the endocervical
swab followed by the female urine and
you see chlamydia in blue and gonorrhea
in orange and we see this pattern just
repeatedly
here is a compilation of studies i've
shown the studies they come from in the
line that says adapted from and i pulled
the data because i actually had the raw
numbers from these particular studies
and you can see the clinician and
self-collected vaginal swabs actually
the self-collected vaginal swabs almost
always perform slightly better than the
clinician clinician collected and the
cervical swabs again slightly lower and
urine specimens again slightly lower for
women but you also see the error bars on
here and so you can see that these are
not statistically different
so if i keep saying these are not
statistically different is there really
a meaningful difference here and i want
to say that this pattern has been
observed over and over and over again
where we see vaginal over in the
cervical over urine and in fact all
three of those sample types are somewhat
better than
liquid-based cytology media this is a
consistent finding spanning more than 10
years with data from every major
diagnostic platform
and so a meta-analysis of this clinical
trial data would be useful and that's a
project that i've recently started so
hopefully we'll be able to get raw data
that went into fda submissions for these
these platforms and we can actually
maybe pool those data and determine if
there really is a statistical difference
and clinician and patient obtained
vaginal swabs are obviously equivalent
in quality but there may be other
advantages to patient obtained sampling
for example
it's been shown that when patients are
involved in their own health care making
decisions they tend to be more active
and more engaged in the process and stay
engaged in the process which might mean
that they're more likely to come in for
treatment although we don't have data to
that effect
so it may be worth saying that if we can
have women participating in their health
care by collecting their own specimens
then they become active participants in
their own sexual health maintenance
so we'll move on to the recommendations
for men so what are the recommendations
well obviously nats are the class of
diagnostic first catch urine is the
recommended sample type
we didn't see any evidence in the data
that urethral swabs ever have improved
sensitivity that was for symptomatic and
asymptomatic
men when we pulled all the data we just
didn't see any difference in fact
urethral swabs may provide a
disincentive for asymptomatic men to be
tested in the future so that was why
first catch urine was the recommended
sample type
do remember that urethral swab for gc
culture is clearly warranted if you
suspect treatment failure
again just a bar chart showing you
the point estimates and the confidence
intervals you see urethral swabs up on
the top and their point estimates are
slightly lower than the urine estimates
which are on the bottom part of the
chart and this is for chlamydia but
again those confidence intervals all
overlap and these are the data for
gonorrhea again with the urine at the
bottom and the urethral swabs up at the
top and no significant differences
between those sample types
now extra general testing so again
obviously gnats should be used for
rectal and oral pharyngeal samples as i
mentioned earlier the treatment
guidelines recommend annual screening
for men who have sex with men now
studies have suggested that screening
everyone in some clinical settings
may be valuable because reported
behavior
may be maybe underestimating receptive
anal intercourse i haven't found this to
be the case in the clinical settings
that i've been involved with but it's
something that's certainly worth
considering depending on the clinic
structure and the population it serves
now it's really really important to
remember
no assay has fda clearance for these
sample types not a single assay on the
market currently has a claim
for rectal or oropharyngeal samples my
laboratories validated several assays
and we will continue validating newer
assays and we don't we have not seen any
inhibition or any other reason to
suspect that any of these assays are not
useful for rectal and oropharyngeal
testing
i did want to share with you just a
little bit of data for those of you who
don't routinely think about extra
genital testing in fact looking at data
from the indianapolis std clinic where i
was until just recently these are data
from 2011 where we have on the top line
the rates for general chlamydia which
you can see in men was about 19
in women about 14
but if you go down a couple of lines you
see the rates for rectal chlamydia and
this is among people who said that they
were having sex with men or a receptive
anal intercourse
17.2 percent of the men who reported
receptive anal intercourse were positive
for chlamydia in the rectal sample
the gc rates aren't quite as astounding
but still 6.6 in the genital compartment
and 2.3
in the rectum but a different way to
look at this is to compare how many
cases we would have identified because
we really care about treating people we
really don't care exactly how many
different places they have it as long as
we've captured that and we've treated
them but unfortunately what we find if
you look at the far left hand bar
in men the majority of infections men
who have sex with men here the majority
of infections were actually identified
in the rectum
only nine of these 113 infections were
actually found in both the rectum and
the urogenital compartment so these are
very localized infections and if you're
not testing the rectum you're missing
the vast majority of cases of chlamydia
among men who have sex with men
this is true for gonorrhea but on
somewhat less of a scale you'll be
missing about 40 percent of the
infections if you weren't doing rectal
testing and you were only doing general
testing but of course our tests can test
both chlamydia and gonorrhea from the
same sample type so we can really
maximize our case finding by running
those highly sensitive tests on both
sample types
for women we see that co-infection is
much more common or infection i should
say in both body sites both the genital
samples and the rectal samples as well
as the genital samples and the oral
pharyngeal samples which i'll show you
on the next slide for chlamydia and
gonorrhea so there may not be as much
pain for your buck in testing women even
those women that report rectal anal
intercourse because they may actually
have enough spread between the genital
compartment and the rectal compartment
that you can identify it with a genital
sample
now here are some confirmatory data that
came out of birmingham where i am now
and this was published in 2009 and here
again you see that you would miss 80
percent of the infections if you were
only testing genital samples from men
who had sex with men
you would also miss about 60 percent of
the rectal samples or the right
infections of gc if you weren't doing
rectal samples and in women there's much
less bang for your buck again
now the oral pharyngeal you're catching
about two-thirds of the sample
population that's infected from any one
sample type so you'll capture about
two-thirds of infections during just an
oral pharyngeal or about two-thirds
doing just in general so if you want to
pick up that extra 30 you probably need
to be doing an oral pharyngeal sample as
well
so just to summarize this and i think i
said enough times nets are the class of
sample or the class of testing that you
should be doing there is no confirmation
required there may be circumstances
where you feel it behooves you to do
confirmatory testing but in that case
you're going to have to think clearly
about what the best strategy is for
using a different platform using
something with different targets using a
different laboratory collecting a second
specimen etc
recommendations in terms of sample types
are vaginal swabs for women
and male urine for men
nets are good
work very well for rectal oral
pharyngeal samples but each laboratory
has to validate this locally and so this
is an area where
clinical services have to work carefully
with their local laboratory to make sure
that they can access this service and to
explain to their local laboratory that
they need the laboratory to go into the
cost involved with this validation
process it's not really quite simple
as a general rule if you want duplicate
specimens for a validation process
that's difficult for rental specimens
because not many people are willing to
give you multiple
samples culture capacity does need to be
maintained and we kept that language in
the guidelines because especially gc
testing
we particularly need to make sure that
we do have isolates so that we can do
susceptibility monitoring and look for
drug resistance in gc there are some
cases of both chlamydia
and gonorrhea
child sexual abuse where culture may be
appropriate but the recommendations for
sexual abuse cases are still gnats not
culture because the specificity is
actually quite good for nucleic acid
tests
and now i want to spend the rest of the
time that i'm going to talk with you
talking briefly about how these assays
may improve both clinical services and
laboratory processes
so the first thing is that these assays
perform so well now and the specificity
is actually so good
that you actually have increased case
finding and
you have a reduction in the false
positive result rates so in other words
clinicians can feel really comfortable
when they talk to their patients they
should be very very certain that they
actually do have
positive results and this is important
because obviously with stis there's so
much stigma and there's so much social
consequences to an infection that we
want to be really certain that we're
giving the best quality results we also
want to make sure that we're identifying
infections we don't want false negative
results either because that can lead to
the consequences we're trying to avoid
such as pelvic inflammatory disease
patients can now collect their own
samples before seeing a clinician i
think this is really key in a lot of
ways
remember that one of the things that
i've been talking about is the fact that
we need to be able to reduce our health
disparities and one of the ways i think
that we can do that is by making this
much more normative so instead of people
feeling like they're targeted and they
were asked to be screened for an stb
because of their color or because of
certain behaviors now all of a sudden
everybody's doing it when you go into
the bathroom you provide a urine sample
you provide your vaginal swab
then when you go in and see the
clinician the clinician is doing what
only a clinician can do and that is
interacting with the patient finding out
what's going on with the patient and
really helping them with their needs but
that specimen for the laboratory is
already sitting there and waiting and
labeled and again as i said earlier even
if a clinician needs to go in and have a
look around there's no reason that they
can't do that just because that vaginal
swab is already sitting waiting for std
diagnostics they can still do as full of
work up as they need to do but not
everybody will require that workup and
particularly when we're talking about
trying to normalize screening
so that we're accessing the testing for
each woman every year the way the
guidelines suggest then those women that
didn't need a pelvic exam don't have to
have one just so they can adhere to the
screening guidelines
i would also mention here that we
probably don't want to use the urine
that's collected during that process
because these are often clean catch
mid-stream urines and since urine
already has a lower sensitivity than
other sample types particularly vaginal
swabs when you consider going from first
catch to mid stream you're reducing that
sensitivity even somewhat more although
we don't know the exact magnitude of
that reduction so again that urine
specimen is not ideal for chlamydia
gonorrhea testing for people that are
doing pap testing and want to use
liquid-based cytology that's still a
possible
option it's still in the guidelines so
certainly that test can go but if they
have the patient collect a vaginal
sample before they've ever gone up onto
the table for their path exam and since
pap exams are now being done only once
every three to five years depending on
the patient's history
we can still have them coming in every
year for their std screen because again
it's normative we're not targeting
people we're not making people feel
different or stigmatized because we're
asking them to collect the sample it's
just the routine
my goal is in life is that ten years
from now if it can be as normal for a
woman to go in and collect a vaginal
swab at any reproductive healthcare
visit just the way she would go in and
provide a urine think how far we would
come and think how much better we will
be doing at adhering to those guidelines
the tests that we have now that allow us
to use vaginal samples allow us this
opportunity to move the field forward in
that way
finally extra genital sampling may
really improve case finding and this is
particularly relevant for any practices
that serve predominantly men who have
sex with men whether it be an hiv clinic
or whether it be a well men's clinic and
you are just trying to do screening and
prevention it's it's really important in
order to find the infections that are
out there and that are asymptomatic
that screening of extra general sites be
done i will say also that i've done a
number of studies where men have
collected their own rectal samples and
in fact they tend to prefer that to
having a clinician do it because it's a
somewhat humiliating procedure but men
don't mind just providing their own
sample and you can use that sample
because the tests that we have today are
so very very sensitive
but it's not just the clinic that
benefits the lab obviously benefits too
all of the next generation assays are so
much vastly improved compared to the
assays that we started with in the 90s
this is a study that i did while we were
still at indiana and we looked at the
turnaround time to results for a number
of the assays that are on the market
this doesn't have data on the hologic
panther because we didn't have that
assay at the time but it has the roche
4800
the
hologic or bd viper excuse me the whole
logic tigress and the avid m2000 and
what you can see is that these assays
predominantly have turnaround times that
are less than six hours
the roche i have up here a little red
bar because if you're using
the second version of the kobas 4800
it's extended a little bit from a four
hour to about a four hour and forty five
minute assay but what's really important
here is to look at the dark
gray bars and what you'll see is walk
away time and particularly uninterrupted
walk away time where you just leave the
instrument alone and let it run and in
today's market where the laboratories
have to be more and more efficient and
use technicians for more and more
purposes this allows technicians plenty
of time to do other tasks
this is just another way of looking at
the same sort of thing where we're
looking at the percent of time that
people have that's walk away time and
what you see in the lighter gray is the
actual amount of hands-on time and so
you can see that it ranges from about 38
to 16 percent for the different assays
so with these new next generation
automated instruments we now have the
ability to screen more and more patients
and yet not burden the lab horrifically
one thing to be aware of is space the
final frontier as i like to say and
that's an age issue right there isn't it
um
that they do take up different amounts
of space and not only is there the
instrument footprint but then there's
also the workspace requirements for the
bench space and the other storage issues
and the other
manipulation issues that you need for
those different pieces of equipment so
it's something to take into account when
we're making decisions about what type
of assay we want to go to
so i just want to wrap this all up and
leave some time in case there are
questions which i see the blinking light
that there are questions
and my final thoughts here that we
really need laboratory options and
clinical options that help us improve
adherence to the screening guidelines
because we have the guidelines we've had
the guidelines for um coming close to 15
years now and we're really not doing
that great of a job and adhering to them
and part of that i think we can move
past because we now have these improved
next generation gnats that actually can
extend our ability and i think as i've
already mentioned one of the key
features is that we can use
self-obtained samples but we can also
use those self-obtained samples not only
in clinics where it could improve clinic
flow
but also in non-traditional settings so
i've used this sampling method for doing
studies in bars in bath houses for doing
screening routine screening
in
doing routine screening in detention
centers in school health clinics etc so
when we think about asymptomatic
diseases and trying to really improve
our ability
to cover those asymptomatic diseases we
need to be offering screening to people
not waiting for them to come to clinic
unless we can offer them in conjunction
with other surfaces such as reproductive
health care services for women
extra genital testing obviously can
improve case finding in certain
populations and it's certainly worth
considering but it does require
validation within each local laboratory
but the other thing is i think that the
excellent excellent sensitivity and
specificity of these assays really could
encourage providers to offer tests to
more patients because they don't have to
worry as much as they did 10 15 years
ago about the potential ramifications of
a false positive result and they don't
have to worry about missed cases with
false negative results so all in all i
think that the next generation's gnats
really offer us a lot of opportunities
that can help us change our laboratory
methods as well as our screening efforts
and hopefully then actually have a
really profound impact on the rates of
disease in the u.s
and with that i'll thank you for your
attention and i will take any questions
that you have
so
okay
that'll do it thank you
oh i do see there is a question here
what measures should be carried out to
make people
visit the doctor at initial stages if
they're suffering from an std and this
is a really interesting question
the issue here is that most people don't
know that they have an std and so
obviously education and awareness so
people do understand what the signs and
symptoms are all too often for example
if a woman has a discharge she may not
know if it's an abnormal discharge or if
it's normal so that type of education
when women first engage in the
reproductive health
process so when they first come of age
and start perhaps using birth control
pills or having pap testing they should
be given information about what the
possible signs and symptoms are but so
many many people are asymptomatic that
rather we need to say to people this is
something that you do every year in the
same way that you go and have your teeth
cleaned every year you don't wait for
your teeth to tell you that they're
dirty you go to the dentist and have
your teeth clean so these are the types
of things that we really need to think
about in terms of how we educate the
population the biggest problem that we
have right now
is that isn't considered routine
behavior and so people think that it
only happens when we have um some sort
of cause for concern so some sort of
sexual guilt or behavioral guilt where
you think oh i've done something i
shouldn't do and now i have to be tested
so until we can get away from that
attitude and get to where it's a more
normative behavior to have people be
screened then we won't have a great deal
of success in curbing these infections
thank you for your question
all right i'd like to thank you for your
attention and i hope you enjoy the rest
of the conference thank you very much